สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
22 เดือนอะไร
คะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วัน
ศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
21 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันเสาวันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพอพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา
5  17 นกี่นาที 1755 นค่ะโอ 1755 นขอของ
นักเรียนก็จะเป็น
1755 นา5ฮๆโ 5 ๆนะคะนักเรียนครูฟ้ามี
ความสุขอันนี้ปากนะคะนักเรียนปากนะ
คะครูครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ฮะ
โอ้โหครูฟ้าอะไรข้าง
บนผมไม่วัด
อยู่อ้าครูฟ้าบอกว่าฮ่าๆๆอันนี้มันเวลาคน
ไทยเนี่ยได้ยินเสียงฮ่าๆๆคนไทยก็คิดเป็น
เสียงหัวเราะใช่มั้ยเวลาที่เราหัวเราะ
เวลาเราดูอะไรตลกเราก็
จะหัวเราะนะคะฮ่าๆๆ
อืหัวเราะค่ะตอนนี้ครูฟ้ามีความสุขหรอคะ
ใชแล้วถามคำถามเดิมอีกแล้วอ่ะค่ะถ้าครู
ฟ้ามีความ
สุขอันนี้ครูฟ้านะคะทำไมผมสั้นหรอ
คะครูฟ้า
เนี่ยมีผู้ชายมาชอบครูฟ้า
หรอมีผู้ชายไม่ใชใช่ค่ะครูหญิงหือว่ามี
หรือผู้ฟ้าไปชอบผู้ผู้ชาย 1 คนอุยหรือครู
ฟ้าไม่ชอบผู้ชายก็ใช่อีก
ค่ะแต่ไม่ใช่ 1 นะคะหลายคนหลายคนอันนั้น
ครูฟ้าเจอเา้าไม่ได้นะคะแต่ว่าครูฟ้าอยู่
ที่บ้านไงครูฟ้าไม่ได้ไปไหนเลยครูฟ้าจะไป
ชอบผู้ชายได้ยังไงอ่ะอืเจอกันที่ออนไลน์
หรอเป็นไปได้มเล่นเกม
เออครูฟ้าชอบเล่นเกมอ่ะสมมตินะคะครูฟ้า
สมมุติอีกแล้วนะ
คะสมมุติว่ามีมิสเตอร์ครูฟ้าชอบผู้ชาย
ชื่ออะไรคะเอ่อ a ละกันค่ะอ่าเอครูหญิงก็
เขียน A แล้วล่ะค่ะสมมุติว่ามีผู้ชายชื่อ
เอที่เล่นเกมกันแล้วผู้ชายเนี่ยชอบครูฟ
อุ้ยชอบครูฟ้านะครูฟ้าไม่คิดอะไรนะคะผู้
ชายครูฟ้าก็อโอเคแหละชอบๆนิดหน่อยแต่ผู้
ชายเนี่ยชอบครูฟ้าแต่เจอกันที่ในเกมยัง
ไม่เคยเจอกันแบบเจอกันแบบเหมือนครูหญิง
กับครูฟ้าก็เจอกันที่ในซูมเจอกันในซูมยัง
ไม่เคยเจอตัวจริงเออยังไม่เคยเจอตัวจริง
แล้ว 1 วันเนี่ยผู้ชายก็บอกชวนครูฟ้ามา
เจอกันอืแต่ไม่ได้มาเจอกันธรรมดานะนะอ้า
แล้วเจอกันแบบไหนชวนครูฟ้าไปออกเดทแบบก็
คนชอบกันใช่มยชอบกันเนี่ยเวลามาเจอกัน
ครั้งแรกอมาเจอกันใช่มั้ก็บอกฮัลโหลฟ้า
เดี๋ยววันเสาร์วันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันเสาร์ใช่มั้ยวันนี้วันวันนี้วัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์ที่ 23
ตุลาคม
2050 โอเค
มไม่ได้ใช่มั้ยปีไทยหรือปีอะไร
ค 2 ปีฝรั่งปีฝรั่ง
2022 เนี่ยมาเจอกัน
ที่มาเจอกันที่กรุงเทพฯแล้วกันนะครูฟ้ามา
กรุงเทพฯนะคะมาเจอกันที่กรุงเทพฯอืได้
มยผมอยากชวนฟ้าไปออกเดช
อุ๊ยได้ก็ได้เออสมมุติว่ามีผู้ชายมาชวน
ฟ้าครูฟ้าไปออกเดทแล้วผู้ชายก็ถามครูฟ้า
ว่าเอ่อเราไปออกเดทด้วยกันฟ้าอยากทำอะไร
ฟ้าอยากทำอะไรหรอเออในเดทเดทครั้งแรกนะ
อันนี้แบบยังยังไม่เคยเจอกันตัวจริงๆเลย
เป็นเดทครั้งแรก
ไปออกเดทด้วยแรกครั้งแรกครูฟ้าอยากอยากจะ
ทำอะไรนี่ค่ะเราจะสตาร์ทตั้งแต่อันนี้
อะไรคะเนี่ยส้มค่ะส้มผู้หญิงนะเราจะ
สตาร์ทตั้งแต่ 6:00 นค่ะคุณมีแพลนเลยเหรอ
คะเราจะ 18:00 นเนี่ยนะคะเราจะไปวัดกัน
นะโมตัสสะไปวัดไปวัดเดี๋ยววออคุณคุณจะไป
วัดไปทำอะไรคะไปทำอะไรที่วัดงไปทำบุญไง
เวลาคนไทยไปวัดเนี่ยก็จะมีอาหารไปให้พระ
นะคะให้พระให้พระแล้วก็ไหว้พระเราต้องไป
ทำบุญกันค่ะ 6:00 น 7 นแล้วถ้าผู้ชายบอก
ว่าเอ่อผมไม่ชอบไปวัดครับไม่ชอบไปวัดก็
ไม่ต้องเดทค่ะอ๋อโอเคงั้นผู้ชายเดทครั้ง
แรกเนาะยังไงผู้ชายก็ออได้ครับฟ้าอยากไป
วัดแล้วแล้วอยากไปไหนอีกอยากไปวัดนะคะไป
วัดเนี่ยน่าจะถึงสัก
ประมาณไปวัดนานมั้ยอยู่ที่วัดนานมั้ย 8
ถึง 840 นะคะ
อืฟังพระด้วยนะคะแล้วก็นั่งกินข้าวค่ะไม่
กินข้าวดีกว่าไม่กินข้าวที่วัดดีกว่าค่ะ
ไปวัดเสร็จ
แล้วไปไหนต่อยังเช้าอยู่อยู่เลยนะไปหา
ร้านกาแฟดื่มมั้ยไปสวนลุมพินีค่ะไม่เสื่อ
ฟังูหญิงด้วยนะชิดเองอ๋อไปสวนรุมใชมีต้น
ไม้แล้วก็มีบ่อน้ำแล้วก็มีทางนะคะคนคน
เนี่ยก็จะวิ่งอ๋อไปสวนรุมอืไปวิ่งกทำ
อะไรไปวิ่งกับทำอะไรนะต้องทูดพร้อมกันอา
ไป
วิ่งเดี๋ยวยยๆอะไรูฟ้าเนี่ย 18:00 นไปวัด
คุณจะใส่ชุดชุดวิ่งไปวัดเหรอคะเปล่าเขาก็
ใส่ชุดธรรมดาค่ะแต่ว่าเราไปวิ่งด้วยอ๋อ
ใส่ใส่เสื้อยืดใส่กางเกงยีนแล้วก็ไปวิ่ง
ที่สวนรุมอืวิ่งสวนรุมนะคะถึงประมาณไม่
เจอเลย
คปอยากอยากวิ่งค่ะุหญิงมันต้องออกกำลัง
กายนะคะอโอเคอ๋อชวนกันไปออกกำลังกายที่
สวนรุมใช่ค่ะไปวิ่งถึงประมาณ 10:00 นค่ะ
แล้วทำไรต่อคะไปไหนต่ออีกคะ 10:00 นแล้ว
เนี่ยยังไม่ได้เวลากินข้าวเลยยังแล้วครู
ฟ้าไม่กินอาหารเช้าเหรอคะอาหารเช้ากินที่
วัดค่ะครูหญิงออกินไปแล้วใช่ไหมยที่วารด
อาหารที่เอาไปทำบุญอร่อยนะคะนักเรียนอาห
คนทำอาหารอร่อยๆมาทำบุญที่วัดเยอะใช่ค่ะ
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ย 10:00 นก็วิ่งที่สวน
ลุมพินีใช่มั้ยคะแล้วก็แต่ตัวเหม็นไม่
เหม็นหรอประเทศไทยร้อนมากนะช่วงนี้อากาศ
หนาวค่ะครูหญิงอ๋อก็เลยชวนไปวิ่งได้เพราะ
ว่าถ้าประเทศไทย 40 องศาวิ่งเสร็จผู้ชาย
เนี่ยอืฟ้าอะไรเหรอผู้ชายน่าจะ
เหม็นเพราะว่าเหงื่อ
ออกอ่ะยังไม่ได้เวลาอาหารกลางวันแล้วจะไป
ทำอะไรต่อทำอะไรต่อดี
น้าทำอะไรดีนะขอคิดก่อนนะคะว่ากรุงเทพฯมี
อะไรนะคะอืมเดินห้างมั้ยไม่ไปค่ะคุหญิงไป
เดิน้าไปเดินพารากอนไปเดินเซ็นทรัล
World มีแอร์เย็นๆไปเดินห้างไปเดินห้าง
หรอไปไม่ไปค่ะไปเดิน
เซเว่นไปดี
มยไปเดินห้างดีกว่ามั้ยคะถ้าคิดจะไปเดิน
เซเว่นเนี่ยเอ่อ
ไปูว่าอยากไปเอิ่มถ่ายรูปนะอารแกลอรี่ออ
ไปถ่ายรูปอืมไม่ได้ไปถ่ายรูปภูฟ้านะคะแต่
ไปถ่ายรูปตรงที่เป็นแถวกรุงเทพฯมันจะมี
เค้าเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
แถวแถวไหนที่ไหนเอ่อใช่ค่ะที่ไหน BTS
เหรอคะ BTS ใกล้ๆใกล้ๆกับ BTS มั้ยรถไฟ
ฟ้าเหมือนเป็นวังหรอเป็น
วังอยู่ตรงอะไรพยาเหรออืมมันเหมือนเป็น
แบบเมืองเก่าๆอ่ะในกรุงเทพฯภูฟ้าเคยไป
อยู่นะเหรอที่ไหนอ่ะจำไม่ได้ออืคุหญิงก็
ไม่ไปถ่ายรูปเล่นแล้วกันนะคะครูจะไปถ่าย
รูปเล่นนะคะถ่ายรูปก็ต้องมีกล้องใช่มยคะ
นักเรียนเดินก็คือไปเดินหาที่ที่สวยๆเป็น
กรุงเทพฯเมื่อก่อนแล้วก็ไปถ่ายรูปแต่ไม่
มีครูฟ้าในรูปนะไปถ่ายวิวถ่ายตึกใช่มอาจ
จะถ่ายพวกบ้านเก่าๆคอนโดตึกแถววัดอย่าง
งั้นใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะใช่แล้วไปถ่ายรูปเล่นนะ
คะเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยอ่ะไปทำอะไรต่อคะหิวหรือ
ยังครูฟ้าไปทั้งไปวิ่งไปเดินถ่ายรูปเนี่ย
มันเหนื่อยนะไม่หิวเหรอคะนี่ค่ะก็จะไป
ถ่ายรูปเล่นถึงประมาณ 11:00 นนะคะค่ะครู
ฟ้าคิดถึงการนั่งนั่งนั่งรถด้วยนะคะจาก
สวนรุมแล้วคุณต้องนั่งรถเนี่ยไปที่ถ่าย
รูปเนี่ยอ่ะถึงประมาณเที่ยนแล้วกันแหม
กรุงเทพฯนั่งรถก็หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าไม่ได้ทำมาลเยอะขนานี้นะคะอยู่ใน
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ย 1 ช่วโมงมั้ยขับรถอย่าง
เดียวเนี่ยได้น่าจะได้ออกเดทกันอยู่บนรถ
เนี่ยนะคะประมาณเที่ยนเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็
จะทำอาหารกินไม่ค่ะไปกินบุฟเฟ่ต์ค่ะโอโห
ผู้ชายไม่ช็อกเหรอคะไปกินบุฟเฟ่ต์ตั้งแต่
เดทครั้งแรกเลยเนี่ยอ้าไม่เป็นไรคูฟ้าชอบ
กินบุฟเฟต์ไงก็จะไปกินบุฟเฟ่ต์นะคะที่ที่
ที่ไหนดีน้าอ่ะพาราก้อนแล้วกันบุฟเฟอะไร
เป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์อะไรบุฟเฟ่ต์อาหารญี่ปุ่น
หรือว่าเป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์ที่เป็นชาบูเป็น
บุฟเฟ่ต์ที่เป็นบาร์บีคิวปิ้งย่าง
บาร์บีคิวค่ะตอโหผมเหม็นเลยเนี่ยนะคะครู
ฟ้าใช่ค่ะแล้วกินอืไปกินปากี่ชั่วโมงคะไป
กินบุฟเฟ่ต์เนี่ยไปกิน
บุฟเฟ่ต์
1 ชม
0 เที่ยนเนี่ยเที่ยนเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็ออกจาก
ที่ถ่ายรูปแล้วก็ขับรถมาสยามพารากอนเนี่ย
นะคะที่เป็นช้อปปิง Center เนี่ยก็อาจจะ 1
ชมง
แล้วแต่ถ้าครูฟ้านั่ง BTS  MRT ก็อาจจะ
ประมาณเนี่แหละค่ะ 1 ชมงแน่นอนนะคะครูฟ้า
อือกุงเทพนะ
คะก็ถึงน่าจะกินถึงประมาณ 14:00 นมูฟ้า
คิด
เออคน่าจะได้บถึง 14:00 นล่ะค่ะ 14:30 น
กินเสร็จแล้วอิ่มแล้วกินบุฟเฟ่ต์ด้วยแล้ว
ก็หัวก็มีกลิ่นเหม็นแล้วทำอะไรต่อคะอยู่
ในห้างแล้วนี่ตอนนี้ไปดูหนัง
ค่ะไปดูหนังอืไปดูหนังนะคะดูหนังอะไรหนัง
แอคชั่นหนังดราม่าอันนี้คืออะไรคะเนี่ย
ลำโพงโรงหนังโรงหนังหนังโรแมนติกหนังผี
หนังฆ่ากันไปดูหนังอะไรคะครูฟ้าไปดูหนัง
ผีค่ะหะไปดูหนังผีในเดชครั้งแรกแล้วมันจะ
โรแมนติกหรอไม่โรแมนติกค่ะแต่ครูฟ้าอยาก
ดูนะคะอออ๋อแล้วถ้าแล้วถ้าผีออกมาแล้วครู
ฟ้าตกใจไปตกเค้าทำยังไงล่ะคะครูฟ้าจะไม่
ตกใจค่ะนักเรียนออแต่ถ้าผู้ชายตกใจอ่ะ
ค่ะก็เรื่องของผู้ชายครูฟ้าใช่มยแล้วก็
ผู้ชายคุหญิงเป็นผู้ชายดูอยู่แล้วก็หอด
ครูฟ้าทำยังไงผู้ชายตกใจตกใจต่อยูฟฟ้าเลย
เหรอค่ะเจ็บ
เลยหรือว่าผู้ชายแบบ
้าอย่างงี้ตลอดเวลาโอเคยอุยมันก็คงไม่
เป็นแบบนั้นมั้งแต่ก็โอเคนะก็ไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าค่อนข้างที่จะแข็งแกร่ง
นะนะคะก็โอเคในการดูผีใช่เพราะว่าผู้ชาย
ตกใจก็ไม่แปลกใช่มั้ยผู้ชายก็เป็นคน
เหมือนเราอ่ะดูหนังกว่าจะเสร็จเนี่ยก็น่า
จะ 17:00 นแล้วนะคะครูฟ้า 17 นประมาณ
17:00 นเนาะ
อื
17 ไปไหนกันต่ออีกมั้ยคะหรือว่าตั้งแต่
18:00 นแล้วนะคะครูฟ้าผู้ชายน่าจะ
เหนื่อยแล้ว
มไม่ได้ของกลับบ้านได้มมีอีกมยครูฟ้าคิด
จะทำอะไรอีกมยออยากไปร้านหนังสือค่ะอ๋อ
ครู
ฟ้าอะไรไม่ใช่นี่เอาหนังสือให้ดูนี่ไง
หนังสือนะหนังสือใช่ไปร้าน
หนังสือแล้วไปไปซื้อหนังสือเหรอคะไปซื้อ
หนังสือค่ะไปเดินเล่นนะคะในร้านหนังสือ
ผู้ชายจะทำอะไก็ทำูฟ้าจะดูหนังสือนะคะอื
นั่นแหละไปเดทค่ะไปเดทนะคะครูฟ้าดู
หนังสือผู้ชายก็ต้องอยู่ด้วยกันนะคะไปเดท
ค่ะครูฟ้าคะครูฟ้ากับเค้ายังไม่ได้เป็น
แฟน
กันดูหนังสือเสร็จแล้วคิดว่าจะทำอะไรอีก
มั้ยคะในเดทครั้งแรกนี้ครั้งแรกครั้ง
เดียวครั้งสุดท้ายผู้ชายบอกไม่เอาแล้วไม่
มีครั้งที่ 2 ให้ตื่นตั้งแต่เช้าไปวัด
เนี่ยไป
วัดกูเ
พ่อไปไหนไปไหนไปไหนไปดูหนังสือเสร็จแล้ว
น่าจะถึงประมาณคุณพ่ออยู่ในร้านหนังสือ
นานอยู่นะคะแต่ว่าอ่ะถึงแป๊บเดียวหแป๊บ
เดียวก็ได้ประมาณ 40 นาทีแตู่จะไปกินอีก
ก็ไม่ได้แล้วนะคะก็เจะไปกินอีกนะคะู้หญิง
ทำไมล่ะครูฟ้าเพิ่งกินบุฟเฟ่ต์ไปตอน
เอ่อไปตอน 14:30 นนะคะแล้วก็คงจะกิน
ป๊อปคอร์นด้วยนะคะตอนอยู่ในโรงหนังเนี่ย
ใช่อ่ะไปร้านหนังสือเสร็จแล้วไปทำอะไรต่อ
คะไปตลาดรถไฟค่ะ
อ๋อเป็น Night  market อ่ะเหรอ Night
market นะคะนักเรียนนะคะ Night  market
ก็จะมีเสื้อผ้ามีหมวก
มีอาหารอาหารเป็นตลาดตลาดกลางคืนนะคะนัก
เรียนเคน่าจะเปิดประมาณ 17 นมั้ยอืคิดว่า
น่าจะเปิดประมาณ 17:00 นนะคะ 17:00 นนะคะ
จะถึงประมาณซัก 1 นใช่ออครูฟ้าก็จะไปตลาด
กลางคืนตลาดกลางคืนไปไหนต่ออีกมยคะคิดว่า
ตลาดกลางคืนเสร็จคว่าจะไปซื้อขนมนะคะน่า
จะถึง
ประมาณ
19  30 เดี๋ยวๆๆๆๆๆนะคะจากสยามก้อนไป
ตลาดกลางคืนเนี่ยอาจจะประมาณ 1 ชมมนะคะ
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าไม่คิดเวลาเดินทางในกรุงเทพฯ
เลยลืมนะคะอ่ะ 20:00 นก็ได้
ออแต่ก็เดินเยอะอยู่นะ 20:30 นแล้วกันนะ
คะอืเดินที่ตลาดกลางคืนจนถึง 20:30 นอื
แล้วทำอะไรต่อคะกลับบ้านหรือยังหรือยัง
ยังไม่จบยังค่ะเพราะว่า Night มาเก็ต
เนี่ยมันจะมีห้างอันนึงนะคะชื่อว่า Union
Mall นะคะ Union  Mall เนี่ยมันจะมี
บุฟเฟ่ต์อีกอย่างนึงที่ครูฟ้าอยากกินนะคะ
พ้าจะไปกินก่อนประมาณ 3 ฟ่มื้อที่ 2 ใช่
ค่ะ 21:00 นนะคะก็บุเฟ่ผู้ชายก็แบบอู้ผู้
หญิงคนนี้ถึงเดทครั้งแรกก็กินบุฟเฟ่ต์เลย
ผมชอบมาก
ๆ 22:30 นกิินเสร็จแล้วปป้าก็จะกลับบ้าน
ค่ะนี่คือ
บ้านอันนี้คือเดทของครูฟ้านะคะแต่ว่าครู
หญิงมีครูหญิงต้องสตปแชร์ก่อนนะคะนัก
เรียนเดี๋ยวค่อยแชร์ใหม่นะคะครูหญิงเนี่ย
มีเค้าเรียกอะไรอ่ะเป็นกิจกรรมที่อยากจะ
ให้ครูฟ้าไปทำในเดทครั้งแรกนะคะอะไรล่ะ
ครูหญิงผู้หญิงไม่รู้ว่าประเทศไทยมีไหม
แต่อยากให้ประเทศไทยมีจะเหมาะกับครูฟ้านะ
คะเพราะว่าคนส่วนใหญ่ก็ไปดูหนังใช่มั้ยไป
กินข้าวทำอาหารกินเองเี่ครูฟ้าเไปวัดวัด
ด้วยนะคะแล้วก็ไปกินบุฟเฟ่ต์นะคะส่วนใหญ่
เดชครั้งแรกเราจะไปกินร้านอาหารแพงๆใช่
ไหมแต่แน่เป็นอีกกิจกรรมนึงที่ครูฟ้าน่า
จะชอบนะคะอะไรทำอะไรคะเวี้ยงขวานค่ะ
โหูฟ้าเคยเห็นยังไม่เคยไปเลยอันเนี้ยคือ
ขวานนะคะนักเรียนที่ผู้ชายเนี่ยเขาถือ
อยู่ก็คือขวานใช่มยเนี่ยอันนี้ก็เหมือน
กันโอแต่เขาต้องมีเทคนิคในการถือเหมือน
กันเนาะ
ใช่สแล้วเราก็นะคะเขวี้ยงขวานไม่รู้ว่า
ประเทศไทยมีมยอ่ะมีครูฟ้าเคยสอนนะคะใน
ประเทศไทยมีค่ะ่เนี่ยแต่ว่าจากดูจาก
กิจกรรมในเดทครั้งแรกของครูฟ้าแล้วุหญิง
คิดว่าครูฟ้าไม่มีเวลาไปเขวี้ยงขวานนะ
คะเอ้าก็ไปวันอื่นไงเออแล้วู้หญิงก็คิด
ว่าครูฟ้าน่าจะชอบอันนี้ด้วยไงอ่ะอันนี้
ไปสวนสัตว์ครูฟ้าอาจจะไม่ชอบหรือเปล่า
อืไปสวนสนุกี่ตอนแครูฟ้าจะไปสวนสนุกนะคะ
แต่ครูฟคิดว่าเอ๊ะเวลาไม่มีและมันต้อง
อยู่ทั้งวันเนาะไปสวนสนุกอันนี้แบบอันนี้
คือคนไทยมากๆคนเอเชียนะคะเดทครั้งแรก
เนี่ยไปสวนสัตว์นะคะแล้วก็ไปสวนสนุกแต่
คิดว่าฝรั่งอาจจะไม่ไปมยไม่ค่อยมีนะแต่คน
เอเชียไปนะคนญี่ปุ่นก็ไปนะคะเวลาเราอ่าน
การ์ตูนใช่มอันนี้ก็คือเป็นกิจกรรมนะคะใน
เดทแรกที่ครูฟ้าเคคิดเอาไว้ว่าถ้า 1 วัน
เนี่ยมีผู้ชายมาบอกว่าฟ้าเราไปเดทกันมย
ครูฟ้าเขาอยากทำอันนี้นะคะนักเรียนต้อง
คิดดีๆนะคะตื่นตั้งแต่เช้าไปวัดนะคะอาหาร
มื้อแรกที่กินด้วยกันก็คือในวัดนะคะผู้
ชายอาจจะหนีตั้งแต่ตอนนั้นแล้วก็ได้นะครู
ฟ้าผู้ชายรู้แพลนปุ๊บไม่ไปแล้วค่ะไม่ไป
เลยเลยผู้ชายบอกโอ้นะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะถ้า
เป็นนักเรียนมีคนมาชวนนักเรียนไปออกเดท
ครั้งแรกนักเรียนอยากจะทำอะไรไม่ต้องเยอะ
เหมือนครูฟ้าก็ได้นะคะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าผิด
เยอะๆนะคะเดี๋ยวไม่มีเดี๋ยวนักเรียนไม่
ได้ฟังภาษาไทยไงแต่นักเรียนน่ะอยากจะทำ
อะไรนะคะก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้เนาะส่วน
วีดีโอนี้ไปแล้วนะคะคุณฟ้าเน่าจะหิว
บุฟเฟ่ต์แล้วอ่ะค่ะนักเรียนหิวค่ะเดี๋ยว
เรามาเจอกันใหม่วีีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดี
สวัสดี
ค่ะ